[Musik]
meinst du nicht vorbei ich ein anderes
video gesehen
über der tür bevor ihr weitermachen es
fehlen ihr noch 6500 ohne scheiß alter
bis zur million also 600 es noch nicht
abonniert haben ganz kurz abonnieren und
dann haben wir es gleich sie etwas und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich
muss sagen ich hab ein bisschen länger
überlegt ob ich diese videoreihe
überhaupt starten soll weil eigentlich
passt es vielleicht obwohl es ist auch
was was man testet und ich teste ja sehr
oft sachen ich wusste am anfang nur
nicht ob das so gut und mein content
passt aber ich habe mir gedacht da
kommen wir probieren das einfach mal aus
und zwar ist das seid wirklich sehr
langer zeit mal wieder ein video wo ich
sagen dass er das ist nicht meine eigene
idee also ich habe man die komplett
selber ausgedacht ich bin darauf
gekommen weil in amerika ist das gerade
in hama hat anscheinend und früher habe
ich öfter mal so amerikanische trends
nach gemacht jetzt schon lange nicht
mehr
deswegen es ist mal wieder an der zeit
ich habe mich jetzt ein bisschen damit
beschäftigt und zwar auf tik tok kennt
man ja leider sind gerade so live hacks
voll das thema da gibt es bei 3,2
millionen beiträge zum hashtag live
hacks oder wandert sogar so zum thema
auf den top-sechs total im trend ich
sehe sie gerne 3,2 milliarden aufrufe
auf dem hashtag live act dementsprechend
gibt es auch viele videos auf youtube
hit leute diese live hacks nach machen
um zu checken ob die wirklich lesen oder
face weil das in sachen dabei ohne
scheiß davon glaubst du nicht dass das
wirklich funktioniert und man ist davon
funktioniert halt wirklich manches auch
nicht deswegen habe ich mir heute selber
live hacks rausgesucht die mir halt
angezeigt wurden irgendwelche
gerade sind und so die ich euch jetzt
erst mal zeigen möchte ihr werden
wirklich sehr erstaunt sein
und dann habe ich einiges vorbereitet
dass wir die auch mal ausprobieren
politisch ist das gut
schon interessant oder dann hast du ein
gummiband tag nicht es ist kein gummi
welt geholt das so aussieht
also ich mag es eigentlich immer so
braucht keiner angst haben recht heftig
nämlich das gummi man kommt hier rein
unter den kleinen finger kann man hier
dann so richtig schön fest drücken dann
einmal am handrücken rum und hier vorne
dann einhaken und jetzt muss man
eigentlich nur hier hinten los lassen
du machst halte auch den immer hoch dann
ist nicht in sicht
ach so einfach mit der hand ruhig
bleiben
das war das wort das war richtig gut ist
doch eine zähle ich auch durch und
treffen okay du sollst die linse
einfaches treffen da hat es einen
schnauzer also es geht schon immer
leicht so weg weiße aber es funktioniert
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich das
hinkriege also hier funktioniert jetzt
komme ich finde ihn so genial ich kann
ihnen also ich könnte ihm nachmachen
aber es wird jetzt nicht viel bringen
ich wollte euch nur mal zeigen weil ich
den sofa ja auch gerade für mich wenn
ich irgendwie ein schlüssel mal jeden wo
verstecken muss
grill oder sonst wie jetzt auch gefeiert
heute heute keine kommentare haben wir
zum nächsten live act den wollte ich
unbedingt mal ausprobieren weil wir
haben hier nämlich das problem dass bei
uns im bad diese armaturen die sind ja
ein bisschen das ja ein bisschen kalk
darauf reiste und da habe ich jetzt
folgendes gefunden also anscheinend soll
das mit zahnpasta komplett sauber gehen
ich bezweifle dass also unsere armaturen
einer duscht die sind schon echt nicht
mehr so neuen oder also schon neu aber
ein bisschen zwar direkt das mal
probieren alte leute hier kann man es
sehen da sind nämlich das muss
eigentlich mehr saubergemacht werden
das wird ja auch nicht besser haben wir
uns noch länger nach hinten raus schiebt
deswegen seht ihr jetzt hier aber wie es
vorher aussieht ich habe mir jetzt
jemand ein schwamm und zahnpasta besorgt
und wir schauen ob das funktioniert
hatte das mittlerweile ohnehin etwas
heimisch also erstmal die sagen dass
sein wirken lassen ein bisschen
[Musik]
draußen im deckel
so passte jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wir
lassen das mal ganz kurz noch ein leben
also man erkennt auf jeden fall noch so
ein paar rückstände wie sollen wir einen
leicht zwischendurch machen ob er kommt
dann china unter anderem live act ok
also ich bin echt gespannt ob das gleich
funktioniert das nächste wäre das auch
interessant weil ich weiß noch wie oft
haben wir uns hier schon ausgeschlossen
ja schon auf dann musste immer ein
schlüsseldienst kommen und wir mussten
einmal 90 euro bezahlen und einmal sogar
180 mal sonntags war die hatten ruhetag
und dann habe ich das hier gefunden
haben und einfach abziehen das selbst
also sagen haben ist habt ihr sonst
nichts gefragt und natürlich oder vor
allem das war doch auch der das geld
werden dann kamen nämlich irgendwann
diese firma auch uns zu und meinte ihr
habt eure rechnung nicht bezahlt habe
ich so viel wir haben unsere rechnung
nicht gezahlt ich hab das baden gegeben
180 euro weil das wahrhaben wollte und
dann haben wir den rausgeschmissen weil
dann immer gemacht hat
abzocke also habt immer ein schlüssel
dabei oder wenn der nächste live auch
hier punkt sind ich weiß es nicht wir
haben auf jeden fall schon eine
sicherheitstür nur wenn die nicht
abgeschlossen ist kann sein dass es
funktioniert ich bin mal gespannt
zur ihrer taktik
[Applaus]
ich habe niemals mit dieser tür meinst
du nicht mal wobei ich noch ein anderes
video gesehen hat von einem youtuber der
türen die haben die auf gekriegt wir
schauen wie juniper days ist klasse
er holte die bizarr wenn ihr müsst ihr
die beatles karte das ist ein guter
bürger laden köln dass er noch zwei euro
drauf gewesen die in der 2
darauf ob die karte mit zwei euro mit
hier rum trägt ja da war eigentlich war
ich würde sagen wir machen das jetzt mal
nach der doch von hier ungefähr bis nach
oben geschnitten wird
ich mache das jetzt auch jetzt noch
übrig gelassen na ja so ne also dass es
wirklich bei so ganz standardmäßigen
laut tönen geht die man auch einmal
eintreten kann haben wir schon gesehen
das glaube ich auch jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das dann auch bei kühlen
geht wo es sich das theoretisch auch
lohnen würde die aufzumachen wenn das
geht sollten wir das veröffentlichen
es geht nicht wahrscheinlich also die
typ ist jetzt halt nicht abgeschlossen
[Applaus]
ich dachte das wäre aber das klingt
nicht so etwas geht nicht ich glaube ich
dass das geht das klingt doch gar nicht
also weiter bei so laut türen geht das
easy anscheinend wenn man dann wirklich
so eine vernünftige für auf kriegen
möchte würde ich mal sagen gescheitert
so jetzt müssen wir das bad jetzt bin
ich will erst mal sagen dass ich mit dem
schwarzen noch mal rüber gehen
so hat mit wasser oder
das würde zu sagen es ist auf jeden fall
schon besser aber nicht so das ist halt
komplett sauber ist so wie im video
aber ich denke schon dass wenn man da
jetzt noch zwei mal rüber geht mit
zahnpasta das ist dann natürlich noch
besser ist hier auf jeden fall einen
vorher-nachher-vergleich und dann werde
ich im nachhinein entscheiden
auch das zählt oder nicht die leute
kommen wir zum nächsten ich weiß gar
nicht wieviele sollte ich so eine folge
reihen dem okay das wäre jetzt sollen
schon der fünfte ich weiß nicht was ich
vom nächsten halten soll ich weiß auch
nicht ob ich das richtig als live-act
einstufen würde aber ich zeige
was wir zusagen machte
weil wer schafft so eine ganze packung
angeles alleine man ist das ja meistens
schon an verschiedenen tagen oder man
teilt es sich halt deswegen würde ich
schon sagen dass es sinn macht wenn es
um sie geht es im video aus dem wissen
aufgebaut
ja okay also ich habe hier die billig
variante gewählt das hat glaube ich zwei
euro weniger gekostet oder so aber ist
vom ding hier das gleiche wenn erstmal
gespannt ich habe hier schon versucht
also es ist auf jeden fall glaube ich
möglich die frage ist nur ob es auch
wirklich so einfach geht
[Musik]
er gilt also an sich ich dachte
eigentlich dass väter sauerei so weiß
aber wohl dass wir nicht also man könnte
es sich ja jetzt schon teilen ohne dass
man irgendwie seine hand versorgt oder
so deswegen würde ich mal sagen das ist
auf jeden fall gar keine schlechte idee
oder vielleicht muss man direkt machen
nachdem es aus dem gefrierfach ist dann
wäre es wahrscheinlich noch besser ich
habe jetzt mal bewusst zehn minuten
aufbauen was man vorher ich habe das
problem ist nur wenn man es jetzt ist
das halt so ein bisschen bargeld
ich sitze und der immer noch ich habe
auch pause gedrückt ist rechtlich habe
auch nichts mehr zu tun sollte dann doch
denn hier
wir sehen jetzt gleich wieder solche
einen habe ich noch der sv airports wie
man die rein ist auch ein bisschen eklig
aber die institute tipps okay leute hier
immer die zahnstocher
das sind die senioren stäbchen genau
bisschen klopapier ein bisschen bevor
anfang
man muss sagen mein ding kannst du es
mal film das sind meine airport sie sind
auch wir halt dreckig ein bisschen so
ist halt so meister das sieht
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen eklig
aus aber ich denke mal dass es bei jedem
so deswegen würde ich sagen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so leute ziehen wir hier ein bisschen
alkohol und nicht so viel natürlich weil
die sollen ja kein wasserschaden
bekommen
[Musik]
doch hier also ich habe jetzt nicht mehr
fünf minuten gereinigt und ich muss
sagen es sieht auf jeden fall schon
wieder zuwächse und auch jetzt gerade
hier so diese höhe von den dingern weiße
höhen des original das natürlich sind
das original weiß man dass man nie das
stimmt ja also ich finde auf jeden fall
ganz gut von daher würde ich auch hier
sagen live-act daumen nach oben leuchten
jetzt sagt haye macht davon auf jeden
fall mehrere partys last nur nach oben
da ich würd sagen weil 6000 kommt auch
ein teil aber nicht den kanal es fehlt
nur noch sechs und halb 1000 so bis zur
millionen einfach 6100 leute die jetzt
schon nicht abonniert haben abonniert
einfach kurz den kanal das war's
instagram alex wie wir sehen uns dann
morgen um 20 uhr wieder bei morgen des
freitag die freitags schon geht's um 20
uhr haut rein